so
[Music]
well the first move i get out of the way
and i'm already on the outside
so i only have the inward spiral on the
outward spiral so i don't have this
thing
okay but here i move out of the way
and it takes it right into the next
strike and up
i'll move inside outside right into that
strike
[Music]
round
this way this right into the stripes
[Music]
okay your tummy must uh compliment
what you're doing so you want to hit his
head so it turns
i don't want to hear too
it can't be like that with that hop so
this moves oh it hits
there and turning his head brings him
more into the position
boom turn his head
oh
[Music]
fix this right thing okay in the same
way that i can't
stop to hit meaning my nagging was that
can't
be fighting against the striking tactics
though this pause is not valid striking
attack
so same way this that's gonna subvert my
throwing because i'm pushing them away
from me
okay but so too is this path
i got a long way to come back to this
technique so you have to
round your cycle of action into the next
cycle of actions
let's just boom pop and it goes right to
that elbow
pop right to the elbow boom right to the
elbow
don't throw the strike at such a weird a
weird angle
that this is reversing now
circle boom right to the eye
strike goes right into the elbow
leave the engine off
okay on with this pistol so
i'll bring this hand only to there
because i'm bringing it to the
elbow the elbow is the throw
so
the wrist supplements the elbow don't
come around to the wrist
first so i pass
it boom elbow then here you already have
the throat
you already have this throw bring the
elbow into this row and then find the
wrist
[Applause]
boom
and this version because you find the
wrist last
you're going to come here and you're
going to fold it in
here so you have right angle
right angle boom
bring that to your body body
and you just start dropping it
don't crawl around your bouquet
boom pop my body
i'm dropping it